hello I'm Karen Colburn I'm the manager
or the digital library initiative of
module I menorah Kaiser wgbh television
so today we've seen a lot of
presentations referencing broadcasting
programs from WGBH and I'd like to talk
about our archives and how we're opening
up access and 50-plus year history
programming WGBH open vault embodies an
evolving framework for preservation of
an access to materials from the WGBH
archive that would have generally been
unavailable for educational use while
not completely open content yet and the
materials are not downloadable from
Olympic ulation within the classroom
open vault presents the merging set of
tools to needle educators to interact
with Richmond interiors open vault
builds upon with lessons learned from
the past and the emerging technologies
that allow us to present information and
new and exciting reads thanks to funding
from the National Endowment of the Arts
national humanities and the Institute
Museum and Library Services wgbh media
librarian archives had created three
standalone websites for particular
titles from the collection new talent
workshop based on experimental video art
see brother a local series on
african-american african-american
community in Boston and the ten o'clock
news the local nightly news station was
on air from 1976 in 1991 resource tools
and functionality developed in
sophistication between 1999 when new
television workshop was launched 2001
when see brother was launched through
2003 with the ten o'clock news
while each side presented presented a
deep finding and there was no ability to
link the collections across search
across the entire concert limiting their
usefulness because they were separate
silent collections open vol amalgamates
the information resources from previous
collections as approximately 50 new
assets from wgbh archive and features a
greater range of functionality to enable
educators to interact with the resources
it provides a framework for the future
preservation of the wgbh archive
gradually open up opening up the rich
media for educational use interviews
from war and peace in the nuclear age
Vietnam a television history pressing
the people and five public domain assets
to contextualize the interview material
comprise the new assets we created
digital files for all of our material as
well as clips that we'd be displayed on
the website this is especially important
for some of the 20 year old war and
peace and nuclear age tapes there were
already showing signs of deterioration
the new resources give us the
opportunity to consider what
functionality you wanted to incorporate
into the new site and like share with
your picture I will pin vault
illustrative choices we need
the opening home page offers a mosaic
that gives you a glimpse into the
treasures of the archive as you scroll
across each tile it displays the title
of the item in top left corner
click on any item and you'll be taken to
that resource here we have the main
description for the iota including
series program and clip description to
the left of the video we have the
transcript this shows you the section of
the transcript relating directly to the
streaming club click on full transcript
and you before so again and you'll be
showing the full raw interview
transcript broken up into chapter
headings click on any hair do and you'll
be taken directly to that part of the
interview
the notes feature once you've signed in
of course allows users to create notes
on a particular resource for now this is
an individual to the user on the website
it's not interactive not taking more of
that later but we do see this as a way
for to meet the site useful to educators
as the create lesson plans and scholars
as the carry out research they're stored
in your list and again once you've
signed in which I shan't bother here you
can delete and update any of you notice
in your list and reorder things in your
list so that you can you can keep up to
date with the the research notes you're
taking
so we made the colors on the ski on the
website and make sure it's a very
vibrant quite light colors so i
apologize if some of you can't see texts
on the the on the webpage i know some of
its quite light but here on the webpage
we we have the ability to send a URL to
somebody else and again we see this as a
way to share information among educator
some scholars and public so they can be
directed directly to a page that your
interest in ensuring them and you can
put messages on that as well so you
could always cut and paste your notes
into the body of the email for a student
to to use we also have people who liked
this also light and we wanted to have an
ability to have both functions that were
attractive to educators and scholars but
also a lot of them a lot of functions
that would be interesting and fun to
play by with the website so we have
people who liked this also liked witches
oops which is based on netflix or amazon
principal we're when you're on a page
you'll be sure items of similar interest
so for example with President Carter
salt in Afghanistan we have a nuclear
physicist NGK main on policy and helps
MIT pages that you can click on to as
part of our mission to make content
available to educators media library
knife archives does want to expand the
use of materials on the website as such
a proportion of the interviews are
available and DVD it costs to educators
so they'll have the full resource for
use no learning environment our hope is
to eventually have complete video
streaming on the site but as we know
bandwidth as always
issue as our arose considerations and is
something that we're looking into for
the future and possibly internet2 will
help us to achieve some of the goals
that you want to go forward with
so while the ability to manipulate
resources and website as of crucial
importance to user experience the
ability to search and browse a
collection is often what marks a website
notice a useful resource for scholars
and educators within our budget and
timeline you wanted to create as many
search and browse options as possible to
offer it to offer different up differing
types of users past exploding the assets
on the website we have a simple keyword
search or an advanced customized search
that can be limited by deep title etc
within the basic search for example
should i put in savoy cafe i'll bring up
her an item with the vocalist merely
talking about and Boston nightclubs in
the 1950s and I'll just play that for
you they do is play this progressive
streaming and this is only a minute long
sword see what you do when I came here
man sample swinging and the Sephora one
day after so that's a little before my
time so when you tell me that support
with the best new team and columbus
that's right about that again yeah go
ahead quite you don't cause him to move
at that time
roll fire happened and was something
came down for the safety of public all
night clubs had to be closed pending an
investigation and exits they had to
close up an elysian I happen to
meanwhile so instead of fixing up the
exits it look real okay if that's how
that happened that's kind of an
interesting you in a story it is
actually a good because when you start
to say that the support movement overall
NASA where I yeah first my things where
longer actually you know most people
identify the woman was on that set yeah
which I do in the night came here any of
the things was going while I have it I
in fact novella Taylor was working a
negative means I came here it's just
small quick so the other ability people
wanted to have is to browse in various
fees so we have a very simple
alphabetically by people or by ceilings
and the series listings are awaited by
the video clips first then programs and
transcripts because we felt that the
moving images are what people are really
looking for more and more on websites so
we lead them specifically we also have
browsing hierarchy which is based on
Merlot and for those of you who don't
know Marlo it's the multimedia
educational resources for learning in
the online of teacher and we need are
browsing hierarchy five levels deep
which means that educators can be as
broad or a specific in their browsing as
they choose so for example if we go into
science and technology we can we can go
down as far as you know we can go down
into engineering and then from their
eyebrows down further so wrong doing
general search it gives people different
paths to to work through materials
we currently have over 1300 assets on
open vault of which 5 over 550 have
student clips the access we're creating
to the wgbh archive materials for
educational use is an ongoing evolving
process in collaboration with UMass
Boston and the CCN MTL here at Columbia
we do hope soon to have the opportunity
to work with film based series Vietnam a
television history a mammoth
preservation project in and of itself we
hope to expand on the architecture of
the website by incorporating
functionalities such as interactive nor
taken and sort of tagging as well as CCN
MTL using core materials to create
learning environments we see future
collaboration with educational
institutions as vital to the ongoing
access to materials from the WGBH
archive just of note since we launched
in January of this year and we're
already in the top five for all the
search engines which is nice for open
vault of course WGBH open vol princes up
straight away and finally I want to
really thank the Institute of Museum and
Library Services for funding open vault
it's important that we get this funding
to really open up our archives on the
way of for educators